And the answer is no. This is a case of what we call reverse causation.
You can argue that the size of the fire causes the number of firefighters that is being destroyed,
and that's because the bigger the fire the more firefighters the fire department will send.
Now our graph, which shows the correlation between these two
variables is oblivious to the direction of this arc.
You could conclude size causes this and fire than the firefighters.
You could conclude the number of firefighters causes this size.
In both cases you could use exact the same data.
But when I put it this way, it's pretty obvious that the right answer should be the size of the fire
causes the number of firefighters to grow up and it's not from the data itself.
It's because we know there's something about fire and firefighters.
It's impossible to deduce from this data that it causes a relationship.
It could be just coincidental or that cause a relationship could go either way.